i need to ask um just one more question
about one of your iconic roles um
because i heard that you didn't you
almost didn't get cast in as good as it
gets that is one of my favorite films of
all time such a good movie yeah so lucky
lucky lucky to be in it chemistry the
cast is insane you look at him
another actress doing this role like
you're so perfect what happened
well first i mean
i've been nominated for two academy
awards i was not the first person
offered those parts first of all so you
never know you know what's going to how
i'm happy to take anybody's no sloppy
sex songs no problem oh really yeah
there's since other people or i've been
sent songs and it'll come out with an
artist so that happens i don't care so
that's the first thing and then i think
the director um thought she's too young
she's not right you know i hadn't done
anything like that and i just wanted it
so bad i begged him to let me come in
and audition and i saw him in the middle
of my audition go huh
i wonder
and then the adoption process especially
when you know that someone maybe already
thinks you're wrong yeah
no it's not it's a cold pool that's
going on a date with someone that's not
interested i already know i'm not
interested in you i'll meet you so i
guess waste my time right um they were
brilliant in casting you know that's i
can't imagine anybody else in that in
that role
[Music]